thanks giving à hollywood c'est ça le
quai les avengers va apporter une
montagne de cocaïne sculpteur forme de
d'un parent sont gentils avec ta soeur
elle a eu une année difficile d'isoler
d'interrompre tourné l'an de méchanceté
mais il y aura que moi molly et bb
aujourd'hui comment renvoyer depuis que
son mari le parti mon dieu les
désespérés j'arrive pas à croire tu vois
déjà quelqu'un on salue et coule voici
des saluts j'aime et petit chef des
sceaux lui bah c'est pas grave on est un
comme ça dans mon premier tiroir mais un
peu plus grand j'avais premier habits
qu'on passerait la journée ensemble
c'est juste quelques personnes de plus
sont des petites familles parfaite super
secret s'est jamais arriver quelque part
sans une bouteille de whisky serait pas
fallait transformer ça en gros ce fait
votre projet et maman pourquoi tu le
tiens comme un sac à main
tu fédérait ton copain de s'allier un
peu intense ou site on vous l'a juste
éviter de salir ma chimie sombrant au
moins quelqu'un va baiser ce soir
c'est en faire la paix mais tout ça est
si magnifique pays niçois cette laitue
qui est si fraîche probablement cueilli
ce matin je me trouvais mon plein t'es
pas bien défoncée qu'il soit permis
d'inviter tout ce beau monde parfois il
faut juste montrer ses seins et célébrer
je vous en prie vous montrez pas beau ça
je suis marié vous n'êtes pas autorisés
à boire d'alcool si ça va j'ai importé
de chez moi ça viens pas dit s'il devait
coûter pas je vais devoir appeler la
sécurité qu'est ce qui va se passer au
nom
[Musique]